-Welcome back, everybody.
We are hanging out
with Tracy Morgan.
Now look at these dates
are here.
Go see Tracy live
doing some stand-up.
Tracy, you are not afraid
to speak your mind
and you always have a strong
point of view on things,
so I thought right now you could
help some people out there
with big life decisions.
It's time for "Life Coach
with Tracy Morgan."
Here we go.
-♪ Life Coach
with Tracy Morgan ♪
-Alright. You're gonna
get some tough advice.
-Okay.
-Right? Here you go.
How about this one?
-Say, "Well, me and you
going as Jada and Tupac.
[ Laughter ]
You Jada. I'm Tupac.
Don't worry about it.
Will don't mind."
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, man, you didn't read the --
Did you read that book?
-Yeah, I read the book, man.
What's it called?
What's the name of the book?
-"Worthy," I think.
-"Worthy"?
It should be called "Let's Kick
Will Smith in the Nuts."
-Okay. Alright.
[ Laughter ]
Alright. This one...
-First off, I don't even care
about his feelings.
You ain't coming in my house.
Until I get my money back.
-That's right! This is --
How about this one?
-Well, me and my mother
haven't spoken for three years
over potato salad.
You don't put no raisins in
a Black person's potato salad.
[ Laughter ]
So that goes to tell you.
-I totally agree, by the way.
No raisins. No, no.
How about this?
-Well, give your real fa--
Give me a call.
Let's talk it over.
I'm your real daddy.
Give me a call.
-It's gonna confuse them.
Alright.
-I don't care
if you're confused.
I'll give you some of that
SSI check, though.
SSI.
[ Laughter ]
-What's that?
I don't know that one.
Do I know SSI?
-SSI. Social Security.
-Oh.
Oh, yeah. Social Security. SSI.
Who's your --
Who's your biological father?
-Who's my biological father?
David --
Everybody knows. David Ruffin.
From the Temptations.
David Ruffin.
-Yeah, of course.
-David Ruffin
is my biological daddy!
-I didn't want anyone knowing.
I know it's...
-David Ruffin.
-David Lee Roth.
-Who? David Lee Roth?
I don't know no David Lee Roth.
I know David Lee Ruffin.
[ Laughter ]
David Ruffin is my daddy.
All of them jealous.
We thought it was Sam Cooke,
but it's David Ruffin.
-Yeah.
-You know, my grandmother be
getting my grandfather upset.
She said she had something
going on with Sam Cooke.
I said, "Grandpa, she ain't
even know who Sam Cooke was!"
-And who were you talking --
What was your grandpa's name?
-My grandfather?
-Yeah.
-Yes.
-Red Foxx.
[ Laughter ]
-This question says...
-Pee on his shoe.
[ Laughter ]
-Tracy Morgan knows.
Hopefully that helped.
Tracy Morgan, everybody!